cela fait mal à les gommer la capitale
mondiale de la gastronomie n'est pas
paris mais tokyo et c'est un guide
français qui le dit et pas n'importe
lequel le guide michelin qui au passage
dévoilera ses étoiles et 2008 demain le
guide michelin dont on considère que la
capitale japonaise est devenu le centre
mondial de l'innovation et du goût en
termes de cuisine
en tout cas si l'on en juge par le
nombre d étoiles décernées enquête à
tokyo pascal golomer ses liens jérôme
tokyo compterait près de 160 mille
restaurant mais ne les at-on jamais
comptés ce qu'on sait c'est que la ville
est devenue plus étoilé que paris et new
york rennes les étoiles qui se cache
parfois dans le sous sol d'un immeuble
de bureaux une petite salle de 50 m² un
bar pour dix convives tout au plus c'est
la cas shiro mizutani officie chaque
jour voilà quarante six ans qu'ils
préparent des sushis thon rouge
langoustines ou coquillages il achète
les meilleurs produits du marché les
plus frais aussi et ils sélectionnent
lui-même son riz pas un mot juste le
geste sobre et précis pour un peu plus
de 100 euros il vous offre l'excellence
michelin lui a offert trois étoiles même
si je ne pensais pas à moi je me doutais
que des restaurants de sushi aurait des
étoiles parce que les vrais gourmets
savent toujours reconnaître la qualité
d'une cuisine quel que soit leur pays ou
leur culture pendant un an et demi cinq
inspecteurs japonais et français ont
parcouru les différents quartiers pour
sélectionner les 150 établissements
étoilés et il y en a pour tous les goûts
jusqu'au plus français d'entre eux
bruno ménard est fière de ses trois
étoiles fier de les avoir obtenus à
tokyo où la concurrence est rude et le
clients connaisseurs un client qui
apprécient les mariage subtil comme
cette langoustine à la crème de poireaux
et caviar et bruno n'est guère surpris
que le guide michelin face de la ville
la capitale mondiale de la gastronomie
en manche nulle part mal à tokyo ce
n'existe pas
la qualité des produits qu'on peut
trouver ici on trouve cette qualité en
france bien bien entendu mais toute
cette diversité qu'il ya autour ici
c'est carrément impressionnant chez
quintessence la parution du guide a eu
un effet immédiat
il faut désormais attendre deux mois
pour obtenir une table car tout le monde
veut goûter à la cuisine de chozeau
kishida ce chef de 33 ans a travaillé en
france aux côtés de pascal barbot un
trois étoiles à paris aujourd'hui il
incarne le dynamisme de la cuisine
japonaise et son esprit d'ouverture
trois étoiles à son tour c'est souvent
parce que le chef a changé quelque chose
à sa cuisine qu'il a gagné ou perdu une
étoile
donc si je ne sens rien n'y a pas de
raison que je ne les garde pas mes
étoiles aussi subjectif soit-il le
classement du guide offre en tout cas
une belle consécration à la variété et à
la qualité de la cuisine japonaise
injustement méconnu hors de ses
frontières